Welcome back. In the last few sessions,
we've looked at a range of alternative
investing. We started with real estate,
the biggest alternative investment
class, and then we looked at gold and
fine art and uh and trophy assets. Last
session, we looked at Bitcoin. And
earlier in the class, we looked at
venture capital and private equity and
hedge funds, which also are often put
into the alternative investing class.
The reason I'm bundling those is in the
last two decade there's been a strong
sales pitch to endowment funds, mutual
funds, pension funds to move more of
their money into alternative
investments. You can see that shift if
you look at a comparison of how much
went into alternative assets in 2001
versus 2022. An increasing shift into
alternative investments from close to
nothing or less than 10% to 20 25 30%.
Now part of this was driven also by what
type of fund you were. Pension funds and
foundations were much more much more
wary about entering into alternative
investments than family capital. So for
whatever reason, family capital jumped
in with both feet into alternative
investments. And part of the pitch for
alternative investing came from big
high-profile investors
who succeeded by being early adopters.
most famous at least among the college
endowment community was David Swenson at
Yale. You know he was you know you got
to give him credit he saw the appeal of
alternative investing before other
people did. He put Yale a significant
portion of Yale's endowment into
alternative investments and it paid off
for Yale at least in the early years and
we'll talk about what's happened
recently but clearly it paid off. So
alternative investing was sold on the
idea of if you added alternative
investments to your portfolio, you would
get a better trade-off. So this is a
fairly typical graph of the sales pitch
which looks at what happens to the sharp
ratio, the ratio of your return to
standard deviation based upon how much
money you allocate to alternative
investments. So across all endowments,
it's 74. If you have less than 10%
invested to alternative assets, you get
0.54 but more than 30% you make 1 point.
The higher this number, the better.
You're getting a higher payoff for any
given unit of risk. So in a nutshell,
that is the pitch, right? By adding
alternative investments, you get a
better risk return tradeoff. And in the
process, people loaded up on private
equity, venture capital, hedge funds,
and those alter those other investment
groups we talked about. Now this in fact
is coming to individual investors.
People are thinking about how to package
this. So as we get ready for that pitch,
it might be worth taking a closer look
at whether in the last 20 years
institutional investors, these funds
that have moved into alternative
investments have received those promises
of better trade-offs of risk and return.
So this is from one study that looked at
what happens when you add a certain kind
of hedge fund to your portfolio. Right?
In theory, when you add hedge funds to
your portfolio, because they're
supposedly lightly correlated and have
alphas, it should improve your return
risk rate. And what this study found
that if you left your money in 6040, in
other words, you did none of this fancy
stuff of allocating to alternatives,
your shop ratios were barely different
after the investment than before. In
other words, the sales pitch of better
shop ratios don't so seem to show up in
practice, at least for the subset of
funds that this study looked at. In
fact, in a further evidence of this,
Richard Enis, who's been very tough on
alternative investing in general in
terms of the of whether they deliver on
the promise, argued that public funds
have actually lost value because of the
shift to alternative investments that
their annualized excess returns that are
being positive has become negative. That
the adding on of alternative investments
has actually created a negative alpha.
So what I'd like to do in the rest of
the session is talk a little bit about
what it is that's failed in this process
that's resulted in this gap between
promise and delivery. The bottom line is
you look across time the long-term
beneficiaries are more skeptical than
ever before. Yale in fact recently
started reducing its alternative
investing and papers in the last five or
10 years especially have argued that you
know maybe if you properly adjust for
risk those benefits that you saw in
terms of sharp ratios in the early years
of alternative investing have pretty
much disappeared. So let's look at
what's under the surface. What's causing
this failure? First, remember the
correlation matrix that I showed you
when I first introduced alternative
investing. After all, it's one of the
reasons we go into alternative investing
is you look at those correlations that
this is good by adding this to my
portfolio, which is mostly long stocks
and bonds. I'm going to get better
tradeoffs.
It turns out that those correlations
might not be what they might not reflect
reality for two reasons. One is many
alternative investments are not in
traded assets, private equity, venture
capital. You're saying, "But how do we
come up with returns?" They're based
upon people appraising the value of what
they hold. Now, I'm not accusing anybody
of fraud, but appraise values tend to
lag real world values. What I mean by
that, if you know, if you're in public
equities and they're down 30%. There's
no hedging, you're down 30%. But if
you're a venture fund and you're down
30%, it turns out that it often takes
two or three years for the 30% to play
out. There's a lag between when bad
things happen when they show up. And
that lag is going to show up as a lower
correlation. The second, it turns out
that those correlations that look low
are low if you look across all periods.
But during a market crisis, the
correlations start to converge on one,
especially on venture capital and
private equity and hedge funds, which
are after all the biggest segments of
alternative investing. Take 2008, take
2020. I'll wage of venture capital,
private equity, hedge funds were
reflecting what was happening in public
markets in terms of transactions. even
though you might not have seen that in
the appraised values. So the low
correlations might be understated or
misleading at least for a subset of
alternative investment. The second and
this has always been true but people
often underestimate how much it matters
is when you enter the alternative
investment space you're investing a
entering a space that's less liquid.
You're saying who cares I don't need
liquidity. That's what you say right
now. You know when you need liquidity?
During a crisis. And during a crisis, it
turns out that these investments get
even more illquid. So when you look at
the transactions caused in the need for
liquidity, it turns out that even those
people who claim they don't care often
start caring during crisis. It's also
true that many alternative investments
there's a lot of opacity. You put your
give your money to a hedge fund, they
don't let you in on the process by which
they pick stocks. you're on the outside
looking in. Now, in good times, you
might not care that they're opaque. That
you can't look into a venture capital
fund or a private equity fund or a hedge
fund. But we know historically opacity
can also become a device that people use
to hide bad stuff. So, liquidity and
opacity, we underestimate how much we
care until we actually start caring.
And third, and this is something we
talked about in the context of venture
capital and private equity earlier in
this class, as more money flowed into
alternative investing, partly because
they were so good at selling themselves
to endowment funds and pension funds, it
turns out that those alphas that we
observed in each of these classes has
dissipated over time. You saw that with
venture capital over time. You saw it
with private equity over time. You see
it with hedge funds over time.
Increasingly, it's difficult to argue
that any of these groups collectively
deliver alphas greater than zero.
There's still some winners in each of
these groups. The one thing that these
groups have that public equity might not
have is there's more continuity. If you
remember the most successful VCs stay
successful,
become a much more difficult game to
win. And it's and as you know as you get
exchange traded funds and passive
investment vehicles the game is getting
more difficult. I've described this as
the investment world getting flatter.
It's showing up in disappearing alphas.
So the low correlations might be just
surface level liquid illquidity and
opacity are much bigger issues than you
let on until you get into a crisis and
disappearing alphas.
And there's a final component. The cost
structure at many of these alternative
investing vehicles is outlandish. 2 and
20. The 2 and 20 fee that hedge funds
are 2% of your money every year. 20%. I,
you know, I I I can entirely go along
with the notion that markets are
inefficient, that they make mistakes.
But I can almost I'm willing to wager
significant amounts of money that no
market inefficiency is big enough to
cover 2 and 20 in the long term. So when
you have these hefty costs up front, it
turns out to be very difficult to create
that return that you saw on paper when
you were sold that fund. So as you look
at alternative investments, keep in mind
all of those. Now, I'm not suggesting
that you should avoid alternative
investing altogether, but you need to be
picky. And when you look look at it,
it's a correlation that should guide
your choices on alternative investments.
Already you can see that that'll mean
that you should probably not include
private equity, venture capital, and
hedge funds in the alternative space- or
at least private equity and venture
capital. Private equity and venture
capital are actually I think closer to
correlations of one with public equity
markets. maybe a hedge funds but a
subset of hedge funds which have
potentially negative correlations. So
focus on that with real estate. If you
remember the correlations have risen
over time. So you want to focus on
segments of real estate which don't move
with public equity. Second you need to
avoid high cost vehicles. So somebody
comes in and offers to get you into an
alternative investment and says they're
going to take 2% of your money every
year and 20% of your upside. Throw them
out of your office. So there's no way
you're going to cover it. And as a
general rule, you want to keep it
simple. If you are investing in an
alternative where you don't even know
what people are doing, it's so complex.
Probably better better off not investing
in that space. Be realistic about your
own time horizon and liquidity needs.
Don't try to tell people you have a long
time horizon and you don't care about
liquidity. because that might sound
good, but if you truly need liquidity,
then you might have to factor that into
what alternative investments you make
and how much money you put in them. And
finally, be wary of this historical
data, whether it's an alpha or
correlation matrices. Not only are they
backward-looking there hefty amounts of
sampling bias, and there's reason to
believe that at least in this space,
many of these numbers are not reliable
because they're not based on actual
traded prices. their estimated numbers.
Now, of course, as you do all of this,
recognize that the world is changing
with the advent of ETFs. Many
alternative investments which used to be
a liquid are becoming more liquid, more
more transparent than they used to be.
So, keep the door open. If you've never
had alternative investments in your
portfolio, at least be aware that they
exist. Look at the risk return tradeoff
and ask yourself, does it make sense for
me? It might make sense for everybody
else, but it might not make sense for
you. I hope you found this session
useful and I thank you very much for
listening.